after months of eager anticipation
Captain Marvel is finally upon us and so
far both critics and fans think it's
pretty darn okay but that doesn't mean
it's all perfect he has a look at the
four best and four worst things about
Captain Marvel the film is called
Captain Marvel which obviously means
there was very little chance of it
working without the right talent in the
title role brie Larson had to not only
be the first woman to be the sole lead
in a Marvel Studios film but she also
had to play a character who's so beloved
by comic fans that the collective fandom
has their own name the Carroll core and
she had to do it all without the benefit
of having been introduced as a
supporting character first even with all
that other shoulders Larsson knocked it
out of the park
her Carol Danvers is capable hilarious
and pathetic strong vulnerable and
intimidating all at once an acting
challenge made all the more difficult by
the scripts demands that she not even
truly know who she is for most of the
film Larson was already an Oscar winner
star when she was cast in this role but
now she's headed for superstardom
because she nailed this part the films
of Marvel Studios have taken plenty of
flack in the past for the way they look
and feel as fans and critics have
noticed a similar style that seems to
cross between films regardless who is
directing it sure there are some
outliers like guardians of the galaxy
and Thor Ragnarok
but many Marvel movies share a certain
murky dull cinematography as well as
some standard fight choreography and
unfortunately Captain Marvel is no
exception this is especially evident to
join the early fight scene on Topher
where the crease Star Force is ambushed
by Scrolls even action sequences like
the train chase on earth feel
paint-by-numbers it's just too formulaic
to be interesting anymore on the other
hand the Captain Marvel definitely shown
when it broke out of the standard Marvel
box case in point the memory probe
sequence which features alien Scrolls
flipping back and forth through Carol's
memories like DJs scratching a record or
while providing snarky commentary it was
so odd and entertaining that you barely
noticed the fact it was also serving up
massive amounts of key exposition about
both Carol Danvers and the film's plot
now that's how it's done
with so much information flying up
viewers though it can be easy to get
confused so it doesn't help when the
film was generally confusing like when I
had a hard
I'm explaining its own timeline the film
start of an amnesiac car or living on
the Kree homeworld of hala trying to
land her first mission with the elite
star force commando squad later on
though we discover it's actually been
six years since she was taken from Earth
since she seems like a bit of a rookie
it's jarring as it forces you to ask
just what has she been doing for the
last six years why hasn't she searched
for clues to our past before it's a
minor detail but it pulls you out of the
movie right when you need to be pulled
in as great as brie Larson is in the
title role of the film samuel l.jackson
has been stealing scenes for decades and
Captain Marvel is no exception Jackson
seems to be having a blast as a much
younger more carefree Nick Fury than
were used to seeing less jaded and more
open this fury trades one-liners as
easily as he bonds with the film's other
scene-stealer goofs the cuts this is a
fury would love to see more of
throughout the film a Dumba's is
constantly picked on by a commanding
officer Jude Law's young rogue he and
the other creme repeats over and over
again that she needs to control and
suppress her true self in order to
become what they want her to become
control it's a big metaphor for how
society forces people to conform to
other people's ideals but while the
payoff is ultimately satisfying the
setup doesn't feel organic law often
feels like he's simply reading the
movies mission statement rather than
saying things a person would actually
say it's closing you down how it makes
you going perhaps it's asking too much
of a superhero movie to be subtle but a
little bit of new ones would have gone a
long way we've come a long way
as strong as on the other hand like we
said the payoff is great once we get
there in the film's climax Danvers faces
a Kree leader known as the supreme
intelligence who reveals that the Kree
have been suppressing her powers in an
attempt to control her all of their talk
of self control was essentially the Kree
trying to Gaslight her into believing
she wasn't as strong as she really is
instead though Danvers breaks free from
her inhibitors and embraces her full
humanity and locking her true power
instead of being controlled prim and
proper she summons all the
self-confidence anger and righteousness
that have been bottled up kind of done
with you telling me what I can do
it's the culmination of everything the
film wants to say about Carol Danvers
and suppressed people in general its
cheer worthy and it may even bring a
tear to your eye there is one minor sour
notes and the otherwise triumphant
ending though when Danvers faces off
against her former Star Force teammates
it should be powerful but it's not
because the stakes are unclear had she
been training with these people for six
years or she just added to the team for
that one mission are they friends both
sides have reason to feel betrayed yet
other than a couple of throwaway lines
we never really see any emotion from
this faceoff and we also have no idea
how powerful any of them are they don't
really put a dent in Danvers but he also
managed to survive her attacks which is
more than the other Kree soldiers can
say without knowing how powerful her
enemies are it's impossible to feel like
Danvers has ever in any real danger
meaning that the physical stakes are as
low as the emotional ones as a results
the final showdown doesn't land with the
emotional impact a film like this
deserves check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite Marvel movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one